- So, I think the
things we have to do is
always debate everything.
Always debate everything,
become far less
headline readers.
Facebook had
some reporting errors
on things that we never
even reported against
'cause they didn't
really matter. Right?
But everybody hears
that or vice versa.
Whatever the headlines are,
so I think attention is
what you need to trade on.
Here's another one,
I believe that buying,
I am a massive
anti-programmatic and banner,
pre-roll digital ad buyer.
I am at the highest levels
and I just don't think
it's a good idea to be
on WeeklySavings.org
bottom left-hand
corner banner ad
when the justification
is the CPM cost.
Nobody saw it.
If you and I were
doing this chat right now
and there was nobody in here
it wouldn't matter
what the creative is.
And so first we
have to nail that down
and then we have
to nail down the creative.
And I think using the
piggy back off the election,
different people want
to hear different things
and for whatever
you think of it, for me,
thankfully if nothing,
at the most micro levels
'cause there're much bigger
macro issues with politics,
if nothing else people are
now debating, "Oh, right.
"You can't give people
the same message."
The days of marketing of
"Chase: It's for all of you."
(audience laughter)
It's over.
Vanilla marketing
is dead because
we had to vanilla
market for 50 years
'cause they were blunt objects.
You ran a
commercial to everybody
but it meant nothing.
Because when you try to
mean something to everybody
in one fell swoop you
mean nothing to anybody.
(light music)